a ridiculous article that recently
appeared in UCLA student newspaper the
daily Bruin reveals the mindset of those
who actually believe that Islamophobia
is a bigger threat than jihad terror and
it reveals yet again the insidious
agenda of the Hamas linked Council on
american-islamic relations that is care
the articles author
Omar Saeed said it takes a lot of work
to marginalize 3.5 million Americans at
once but the ROTC did just that when
it's stereotyped Muslims to portray
enemy combatants now think about that
for a second who exactly are American
troops facing in Afghanistan
Methodist's Saeed complained during a
training held by UCLA's and California
State University Fresno Czar Mir Otzi's
in early April students acting as enemy
soldiers and combat simulations were
wore clothing commonly worn by civilians
in Arab countries the clothing included
coup FIA's and calls which are better
known as the flowing scarves Arab men
traditionally wear on their heads now it
might seem incongruous and wrong for the
enemy combatants in the exercise to have
been dressed as civilians until one
recalls that the Taliban al Qaeda and
the rest don't usually march out in full
uniform also they often base their
activity in civilian areas in order to
claim that US strikes hit non-combatants
so that they might win points in the
ongoing propaganda war in any case the
civilian dress was not the only aspect
of this exercise that enraged Saeed he
noted at one point in the training major
tyrone Vargas the executive officer of
the battalion and a UCLA assistant
adjunct professor of military science
held a rocket-propelled grenade above
his head and said Allah Akbar in the
presence of cadets Vargas later told the
Bruin that this had been a way to teach
cadets how they would need to decide
whether people approach them as
combatants or in celebration Saeed then
goes on to point out that the phrase
Allahu Akbar is a large part of daily
Muslim worship and life which is
nevertheless become a common
element in Islamophobic jokes and
stereotypes about terrorists now how on
earth could that have happened he goes
on training future military combatants
is one thing perpetuating discriminatory
stereotypes is another he quoted Marwa
refa he of cares los angeles chapter
saying this training negligently
promotes an image of Muslims as
dangerous now the idea that this is a
gratuitous affront is a telling
indication of how far the public
discourse today has strayed from reality
some Muslims are dangerous some aren't
cares objective is apparently to attach
such a stigma to preparations to counter
those who are dangerous that such
preparations will be dropped altogether
but back in the real world everyone
should recognize that care statement is
as absurd as it is subversive does the
u.s. face a jihad threat today obviously
it does do many of these jihadis wear
traditional Islamic garb of course they
do do many of them scream Allahu Akbar
when they're attacking yes once again
it's all patently obvious but a ROTC
exercise that features the enemies of US
soldiers wearing Islamic garb and
screaming Allahu Akbar is now
Islamophobic and somehow endeavours to
marginalize 3.5 million Americans Syed
even claims that the university cannot
expect these students on campus to feel
safe or comfortable knowing that all it
takes for them to be labeled an enemy
combatant is to say an often used phrase
or wear an outfit common in their
country really and when exactly did ROTC
or anyone else claim that everyone who
wears traditional Islamic garb or says
allahu akbar is an enemy combatant never
of course but reality seldom intrudes
upon those who wax indignant about
Islamophobia Syed's article is of a
piece with successful efforts by care
and other islamic advocacy groups in the
u.s. to get all mention of Islam and
jihad removed from counter terror
training an effort that came to fruition
in 2011 when Barack Obama mandated that
there'd be no mention of Islam in the US
government's anti-terror strategy which
he dubbed countering violent extremism
the subtext was and
is that because not all Muslims are
jihad terrorists it is somehow wrong for
the US military to prepare to counter
those who are the end result will be
that the u.s. is ignorant and unprepared
in the face of the advancing jihad is
that what Omar Saeed and kare want
I'm Robert Spencer Schulman fellow for
the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the Center for
security policy